hey Vsauce Michael here and Derek
generate 78 that's so random or is it
what does it mean to be random can
anything really be random what's the
most random thing ever
today let's stop being random and become
brandsmart if something is unpredictable
and contains no recognizable patterns we
call it random so let's begin our hunt
for the most random thing with a coin
toss
the Australian 50 cent coin is one of
the largest coins currently in
circulation coin flips and rolling dice
are not intrinsically random they are
only random because of our ignorance if
we could know every initial condition
the exact forces and properties that
played for a particular flip or roll we
could theoretically calculate the result
before it even happened and sure enough
researchers have built coin flipping
robots that can precisely control a flip
to get the result they want 100% of the
time so here is our question is there
anything you couldn't predict even if
you knew everything a process determined
by nothing and how can you be sure there
aren't any patterns in what you are
looking at maybe you just haven't looked
for the right pattern yet or maybe you
have already seen true randomness but
didn't know it because you didn't look
for long enough as if protected by a
sort of camouflage a random process can
and will occasionally produce patterns
YouTube URLs are pretty much random a
unique one is made for every uploaded
video but sometimes like the proverbial
monkeys typing away on typewriters
YouTube generates a URL that contains by
chance a word the official music video
for 50 Cent's inda Club contains a
synonym for bottom this video was
assigned hello there are some Sexy's and
a sauce
you want to find out if a particular
word has been randomly assigned to a
video yet you can search for it by using
this string in Google the point is
randomness is difficult to identify it
is easier to be certain that something
is not random than that it is but
despite this elusiveness something
interesting is going on right now
increasingly we especially young people
are calling clearly predictable things
random like randomly running into your
best friend at a popular restaurant or
hilariously bizarre combinations of
things that we call totally random
because they are seemingly unrelated
even though of course they were chosen
not at random but in a very determined
way because they are all unrelated those
guys that showed up at the party last
night you didn't know they weren't
randos in a mathematical sense they knew
about the party we're in the mood to go
to a party and we're in the area pretty
predictable actually this non
statistical use of the word random
annoys some people but it's not that far
off from the original meaning of the
word in the 1300s random meant running
or at great speed later it would be used
to describe things that had no definite
purpose it wasn't until the 1800s that
random took on a particular mathematical
definition then in the 1970s mi t--'s
Student Paper popularized the use of the
word random to simply mean strange
of course just because something is
strange doesn't mean it has no
discoverable cause why if we started
calling so many predictable things
random while many theories revolve
around the amount of information and new
people we are confronted with at an
increasing rate now more than ever
before perhaps it's just easier almost a
bit of a relief to call things random so
that we can move on to synthesize other
information take a look at this dye now
as you can see it rolls a five most of
the time but not all the time over time
a sequence of its results will contain
less randomness but it is still random
any face is possible and I have no
guarantee beforehand of knowing which
face will show up the outcomes I'm
selecting from make the resulting
sequence less full of randomness but the
process is still random even though a
dye and a coin are extremely sensitive
to their initial conditions and over the
course of normal use are quite
unpredictable they do over time exhibit
certain biases biases that make them a
bit more predictable and a little less
random than you might think
first of all dice even precision dice
are only quality controlled within a few
micrometers you can check this out
yourself make two stacks of ten or more
similar dice now if you orient each die
every which way you should pretty much
get two equally sized stacks but if you
arrange each stack along a shared axis
so that every die faces the same way any
regular imperfections caused by the
manufacturing process may become visible
but what about coins well some fantastic
research has been done on what happens
when they spin and flip for instance it
has been found that the u.s. nickel is
just the right diameter and thickness to
wind up landing not heads up or tails up
when flipped but on its side about once
every six thousand times its flipped but
what about the fairness of flipping
well if you flip a coin like this for
statistical and physical reasons the
side facing up before the flip begins
doesn't actually have a 50% chance of
being the result instead as researchers
at Stanford have found it actually has a
51% chance in this case it was the other
side though still pretty Randi if you
want a coin flip to be as spare as
possible you should just catch it in
your hand don't allow it to hit the
ground bounce tumble and spin that's
because researchers have found that when
a coin spins larger biases come into
play the shape of its edge its center of
gravity
the heavier side tends to go down quite
often in the case of some coins as often
as 80% of the time it's been found that
a 1 euro coin will spin and land heads
up more often than not and a US penny
will land tails up more often than not
wins fun but like I said earlier
theoretically if we knew everything
about the initial conditions of a coin
flip or a die roll we could calculate
beforehand their outcome why don't we do
that more often well it's extremely
difficult insane amounts of precision
would be required because the smallest
difference between two initial
conditions can be magnified over time
leading to chaotic extremely difficult
to predict results random.org the
service Derek and I used at the
beginning of this video to generate a
random number uses atmospheric noise
it's extremely hard to predict but
technically still a deterministic system
all that noise came from somewhere and
if we could just find out those initial
conditions we could theoretically
predict their outcomes if we want a
system more random than that we will
need to find one that is determined by
nothing and for that let's look closer
quantumly close quantum mechanics may
have our answer
it describes the properties of quantum
Lee sighs things as probabilities just
chances not because we don't know enough
yet to be certain or predict but because
but the idea is there's nothing there to
predict there is no beforehand we could
know whether or not a particular
individual radioactive atom will decay
or not or whatever the spin of an
electron is is only knowable once we
look there determined by a deep-seated
randomness woven into the universe
itself
Einstein couldn't believe this he
refused to accept as he said that God
played dice with the universe but
experiments with entangled particles
have shown violations of Bell
inequalities entangled particles are
particles that exhibit similar
properties even when separated by large
distances now if they agree on those
shared properties to have or are somehow
determined beforehand to have them their
behaviors should satisfy Bell's famous
inequalities but experiments have found
that instead the likelihood of what a
machine will see when measuring one
particle determines how the other
machine will measure the other particle
it is here when we look that the chance
is determined explanations for this are
even weirder but what the results
suggest is that the chance of seeing
particular quantum qualities don't pre
exist they happen when you look so if
you are ever feeling boring or
predictable just remember that you are
made out of octillion
of quantum probabilities dice that don't
tumble in any analyzable way we could
ever
they are the most random thing God may
play dice with the universe but they are
the best dice in the universe and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
but what does it all mean well true
randomness doesn't mean anything
I mean for us to have meaning we need
structure predictability and that is
what I'm exploring over on my channel
veritasium Wow okay so let's go over
there and take a look at what is not
random veritasium let's go I'll see you
guys over there it's gonna be awesome
come with us and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]